in spain sunshine is money
the country relies on tourist revenue to
keep its economy going
and its biggest customers are brits
here on the costa del sol they've got
used to masks
and to socially distancing on the
beaches but losing
british holidaymakers now would be
costly
and painful but it's so important
because it's our
it's our main industry you cannot change
your tourism industry for another one
from one day to
another that's what we have that's what
we live for
there is irritation britain's action is
seen as unwarranted even
as an insult spain is a safe
country for tourists and for spaniards
like in any other european country we
are seeing
outbreaks the outbreaks in spain are
perfectly
controlled there has been an increase in
cases around here recently but nothing
to match the numbers
in the north of this country and that's
what particularly annoys people here
in spain's southern resorts they say
they've spent
months preparing for the return of
holiday makers but are now being
punished for a covered resurgence that's
happening not here
but a thousand kilometers away in
catalonia
today british tourists were still
arriving but their numbers have already
tumbled
only the stoic are persevering three
weeks ago
because we thought it was going to be
safe so and then this has happened
it should have given a little more
warning we needed really but
i understand the situation um but i just
think
you know after four months of us being
in quarantine and now we're just wanting
to get out and about
up in the peaceful sultry hills rob
rents out villas he's
already had a wave of cancellations it's
been very tricky and the phone's been
going
non-stop and lots of emails be coming in
so myself and
my colleagues i work with have been
trying to go through that and
look after everyone's interests as best
as possible
spain's tourist economy is suffering and
this is a tough new blow
but whether it was born of prudence or
panic
well that's hard to know adam parsons
sky news
toro molinos